Caitlyn Jenner is not joining Dancing
with the Stars despite reports claiming
that the 65 year old would be joining
the hit ABC competition show a rep for
Caitlyn confirms exclusively to ET that
is simply not true saying quote there is
not nor have there ever been any
negotiation on this matter Caitlyn's rep
explained that producers did reach out
to see if there is interest on her end
but closed that is the extent of the
communication while Caitlin isn't
joining the show her participation would
have been welcomed in June dancing the
stars pro Derek Hough told ET that he'd
love to compete for the mirror ball
trophy with Caitlyn I'm up for like any
sort of challenge and one thing I pride
myself not myself I what I pride dance
with stars on is taking chances and
doing things are a little bit out of the
box and doing some things that you know
um you know that are inspiring and that
our brave and so for me I say why not
absolutely and his fellow pro dancer
shell Burke echoed that same sentiment
just a few weeks later I think Caitlyn
would be amazing on Dancing with the
Stars the whole family basically has
done it I danced with Rob Kardashian Kim
did it a few seasons ago are you bummed
that you won't see Kaitlyn twinkling her
toes around the ballroom next season on
Dancing with the Stars send us a tweet
with hashtag et now and let us know